what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and old man's will have a manly
video for you today today I'm going to
be talking about one of my favorite
characters in my hero academia I am
referring to the man the manly legend
himself a judoka d Shima aka red riot I
absolutely love making videos on
inspiring characters like Kitty Shima
because I feel like I learned things and
get motivated as I do to research and
writing in this video I'm going to be
going over Kitty Shima's manly character
and his unique powers so stay tuned for
that
also someone wants to count the number
of times I say the word manly in this
video and put in the comments I think
that would be manly AF if you like my
hero academia videos and want to see
more make sure to smash that like button
to let me know if we can get 5,000 likes
I will pick another inspiring character
in MHA there's a bunch after all and
break them down too if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is absolutely
crucial hit that notification bell
because if you don't you will not know
when you might hear academia videos come
out
that's how YouTube works these days for
more my hero academia content and
crucial updates about the new seasons
make sure to follow us on twitter and
instagram at anime up drawer keep in
mind there will be manga spoilers in
this video if that actually bothers you
now without further ado let's man up and
jump into it one of the most interesting
aspects of Kadesh most character in my
opinion is the fact that his upbringing
wasn't glorious and gave no signs that
he was fated to be a great hero when he
was three years old he woke up because
he had to pee he rubbed his eye and
that's when his hardening quirk
manifested for first time he cut himself
and cried this left a permanent scar
over his right eye like I said not very
glamorous then in junior high Kirishima
attended the same school as Mina so they
have a special kind of relationship
because Mina knew him before he was the
epitome of manliness read riot for this
reason some people shut them together
let me know if you ship it or skip it in
the comments at this point this
relationship probably makes the most
sense since Mina inspired him you could
even say mean a hardened his resolve we
do get a flashback in the manga from
Kadesh emos junior high days a kid is
getting bullied in Kitty Shima season
happening he tells the guys to knock it
off because bullying
is not manly at all however they just
throw a rock at his head
Kenny Shima hardens a bit to cushion the
blow to his face but it's clear that
there isn't much he can do with his
quirk at this point his friends tell him
to cut it out and stop sticking his nose
where it doesn't belong but konnichiwa
tries to live by the words of his hero
idol crimson riot who also has a
hardening ability now the Crimson wry
quote is different depending on the
translation I believe the official
English translation uses chivalrous
heart instead of manly spirit even
though manly spirit does seem to be more
in alignment with kiddy chimas character
anyways what crimson riot said was that
as long as you got a manly spirit or a
chivalrous heart then quirks don't even
matter
Kirishima rushes off to try and save the
kid after all the pros say your body
moves before you've got time to think
but then he sees that he's too late Mina
has already dealt with the situation
like a pro
unlike Kirishima she comes off as a
natural-born hero
konishi most friends are terrible
because they're always telling him that
his dreams are impossible they're
weighing him down with doubts and
insecurities I think it's significant
that Kenny Shima makes new friends in
the hero academy who actually support
him even baku go it's like anything
important you try and life if you really
want to achieve your dreams the reality
is you're probably going to have to get
rid of friends who are constantly making
fun of you or discouraging you when you
try to change for the better you'll
probably have to drop those friendships
or at least see those friends less often
and make friends with more positive
people who support you and are in
alignment with your goals Kitty chimas
friends put him down even as they
praised Mina they say that she's going
to go places because she's got killer
physical reflexes and she's great with
people
unlike kitty Shima her quirk is strong
and flashy his friends talk about how
things are different now than they used
to be they say that being a hero is all
about the entertainment factor and
approval ratings and kitty Shima begins
to doubt himself because his quirk is
kind of boring this is why Kitty Schmoe
trains with all his might to make up for
his lackluster quirk his friends are so
negative that they don't even seriously
consider trying out for you a in fact
one insults the other for even
suggesting it you never know until you
try but these guys even at such a young
age have already lost belief in
themselves they have resigned themselves
to the
so-called practicality of the adult
world kitty Shama doesn't even tell them
that he's playing to apply to you a
because he'll just get insulted - he
doesn't know if he's crazy for wanting
to apply
he thinks he's lame he starts comparing
himself and wishing that he had a strong
flashy quirk like Mina's perhaps then he
would have the confidence to go for you
as hero course just as all these doubts
are plaguing him he sees what looks like
a very intimidating villain he starts
destroying a building and Kitty chinois
doesn't start running in order to help
he doesn't move without thinking he's
looking around and worrying about how
there are no heroes in sight he's trying
to convince himself to act in spite of
his fear he's sweating all over and
looking distressed AF but again Mina is
the one to step in she gives random
directions to the Giant and he leaves
just like that Mina was scared too but
she acted anyways
Kirishima wonders why he didn't move he
hears the voice of his friend who said
and I quote dummy we're too plain to be
heroes got a ruled that out from the
start and quote at this point Karishma
is really questioning himself
mommy-daughter our protagonist trump
tend to try to say Bothwell when he had
no quirk
Kirishima couldn't move even with a
quirk Karishma thinks that he is not a
man he thinks that he's nothing as he
scratches UA off his number one choice
for high school just as he's given up
Kirishima accidentally stumbles upon
some extra footage of crimson riot that
he'd never seen before in the interview
crimson riot is asked if he's scared to
charge headlong into danger and he
answers that of course he's scared he
says that there isn't anyone out there
who faces down death without fear only
idiots crimson riot points out that he
wasn't always the man he is now back in
his sidekick days there were some lives
she could have saved but he didn't he
hesitated for a second it was his weak
spirit that doomed those people now I'll
directly quote the rest because I think
it's very powerful
crimson riot says villains are scared of
dying too but I know something scarier
than that a person's final expression
frozen in place the pain I couldn't
prevent it's because I've seen that that
I keep diving into danger for him
chivalry or manliness is a strong spirit
it's not about gender or confidence or
being fearless he just made the decision
that he's a hero so he protects people
he puts his life on the line
because he made that decision despite
his fears doubts and the rest chivalry
aka a manly heart to him means living
without regret after this amazing
interview Kitty Shima decides that he
won't go back on his promise to himself
anymore
despite his doubts he's going to move
towards his dreams of becoming a hero he
applies to UA and he actually gets in he
dyes his black hair red and spikes it up
to reaffirm his commitment to his goal
what Kirishima has learned is the same
thing that mr. Miyagi taught the Karate
Kid it's okay to lose to an opponent but
you must not lose to fear at the first
day of you a Minah is shocked by Kitty
Shima's hair he tells me that he's no
longer going to have regrets he's going
to become a hero who protects others he
tells her to say goodbye to the old
pathetic ham Mina messes with him and
encourages him and Karishma smiles and
thanks her obviously he's not a
completely new man he's in the process
of evolving and becoming his ideal self
even now however he's now committed to
moving closer and closer to that ideal
version of himself every day you know
some people say the rock Lee should have
been the protagonist of Naruto well you
can also make the argument that
kayashima should have been the
protagonist for my hero academia I say
this because Kimmy Shima seems to be a
less naturally born hero and more of a
self-made hero for instance that who has
mentioned ran into hell bath can go
without thinking even though he didn't
have a quirk this suggests that he's got
the natural stereotypical hero inside
him then he gets the most Opie power
from all might in the form of one for
all meanwhile conditional wasn't gifted
with being a natural-born hero or with
the most flashy and opium powers
nevertheless he continues to work hard
in order to overcome the shortcomings of
his character and quirk and I don't mean
to underplay deku story because I do
think he gets a lot of development but
to me Kirishima story is even more
inspirational than that coos now I'll go
into some meaningful highlights from
collisions time in new way to show how
far he's been able to come from that kid
filled with fear self-doubt and
self-loathing Kitty Shima works so hard
that he goes from doubting whether he
should apply to you a to getting second
overall in the UAE entrance exams if
that isn't absolutely amazing I don't
know what is then during the curt test a
pre
Kiesha becomes 1/8 out of 20 students in
class 1a at the unforeseen simulation
joint
Kirishima along with baku go is one of
the first people to try attacking Kuno
Gibby obviously it doesn't do anything
because the nature couldn't get his
quark but it shows how far he's come
from the junior high kid who was
paralyzed with fear when he saw a
villain
Kirishima shows us that with enough
determination hard work we can
consciously change and improve ourselves
in a significant way just because we
aren't born heroes that doesn't mean we
should give up trying to be heroes at
the UA Sports Festival Todoroki freezes
a giant robot and it crashes that on
Kirishima he survives by using his
hardening quark but is upset by how
Todoroki puts the lives of his fellow
students in danger this is another
reason I like Kashima he's a person who
doesn't just value individual strengths
above all else he believes that behaving
virtuously and helping others is
extremely important after all
endangering innocent lives is not manly
at this point he meets Tatsu Tatsu Tatsu
Tatsu who is pretty much a Silver Surfer
clone of Kirishima both of their quirks
are described the same way by hardening
they acquired the ultimate offense and
defense
if Kirishima thought his quirk wasn't
special before you can imagine how it
feels to find out that someone
practically has the exact same one
except the other person looks like the
Silver Surfer so he's arguably even more
flashy despite all this
Kanishka keeps moving forward and
finishes 9th at a 42 in the obstacle
course portion of the festival another
impressive accomplishment for the
cavalry portion even though he's picky
Kirishima convinces Blackwell to team up
with him the two work well together and
their team passes to the next round
during the tournament portion ki Shima
must fight his silver clone in the first
round it's a pretty straightforward
fight they used their hardening
abilities and hit each other until they
knock each other out to break the tie
they arm wrestle eventually because of
kanishka's perseverance that's
what--that's whose iron runs out
allowing ki Schmo to win the
armwrestling match
he then fights back who go bravely but
is eventually overwhelmed because he
overused his quirk it begins wearing off
until it can no longer effectively block
Baku goes explosions but hey if you had
to lose to someone at
she lost the someone asked talented us
Baku go who would go on to win the whole
thing
kitty Sherman goes on to have other
setbacks like losing to some Mentos
during the first term final exam but he
doesn't let that stop him when Baku is
kidnapped
Kirishima is one of the students who
wants to go save him even though the
majority of students are against that
Kaneesha has determined he will not sit
around and do nothing
he tells EDA that if he doesn't act now
and try to save his buddy
he can't consider himself to be a hero
or a man despite the fact that it is
against the law for them to act on their
own against the wishes of the pro heroes
Karishma value something above those
laws he has his own moral compass a
co-ed of manliness and he needs to
follow it even if it means breaking the
law to do what he thinks is the right
thing when midoriya comes up with a plan
to save baku go he says that key Vishwa
has to be the one who reaches out to him
because of their special bond at this
point key Vishwa is arguably bothwell's
only true friend so it has to be him
while Bosco would have hated the idea of
being saved by midoriya he takes
condition was hand and smiles when the
time comes proving that they truly had
developed a great friendship I love the
fact that kiri she must set out to save
Baku go convinced as many people to go
as he could and then succeeded in
getting him out of the dangerous
situation with his own hand truly epic
now let's fast forward to the overall
arc where Kanishka really shines after
factum and Tamaki take care of some
criminals another hitting criminal fires
a bullet at Tamaki that takes away his
ability to use his quirk
Kirishima goes after him kishka catches
up to him and the criminals weak blades
quark is no match for creation was
hardening
however the criminal manages to make any
Schmo feel pity for him after all Kimi
Sherman knows what it is like to have a
lackluster quark so he gets distracted
and lets down his guard the criminal
takes a quark enhancing drug which turns
him into a truly formidable villain who
can create numerous long and strong
blades now his blades are sharper than
Kirishima is hard
Karishma has no tricks all he can do is
bulldoze through his opponent he
remembers Baku go telling him that if he
refuses to go down it means he's
stupidly strong thinking back on this he
has a newfound termination he'll raise
the level of his hardness
he will evolve into an even
harder red Metapod he makes himself
tougher and tougher in order to become
an unyielding wall as a result of the
compressed quark strengthening training
Kirishima is able to attain a new level
of hardness called red ride unbreakable
it is his maximum hardness level at this
point the criminal launches the
concentration of strong blades at
Kirishima and he takes them all on
because there are still people around
him who haven't gotten away yet he tells
himself that he's a steel man instead of
style he'll use brute force to overwhelm
the opponent he rushes through and
knocks the criminal down before the time
limit for unbreakable runs out however
he lets his guard down again and the
criminal almost gets away but that gum
stops him the bystanders he saved thank
you Ashima
they say he really saved them they say
he'll become an incredible hero without
a doubt then factum complements Kanishka
and his magnificent debut and suggests
that it was way better than his own
since vacum is a successful pro hero
that really means a lot this is an epic
moment for Kirishima since he's finally
where he always wanted to be he wanted
to be a brave and strong hero and now
people have acknowledged that he is just
that obviously he will keep improving
but this is a far cry from the afraid
kid he used to be he can't help but
smile and thank factum for the
compliment I also love to see how
positive and optimistic Kanishka is with
Tamaki even though Tamaki thinks that
creation was naturally positive like
medial he doesn't know what we know cue
Vishwa is this way now because of how
much he worked on himself at his beliefs
fast forward a bit and Karishma along
with factum had to fight a much stronger
opponent the two have to face off
against kendo tapa one of the strongest
dudes ever and Haku g10 guy a guy who
can create telekinetic barriers as
strong as a steel wall these two are
members of the a precepts of death
robbers punches are so strong that he
can break through kiddush most
unbreakable mode and even hurt that gum
both of these guys have a really strong
defense so that speaks to wrap us great
physical power here kitty Shima again
has to face his demons he thought he was
finally strong especially after the
incident with the blade criminal and all
the compliments he
afterwards but Rafa shakes his
confidence by breaking through his
unbreakable defence vacum warned him not
to let a spirit break just because his
defense broke because that's when you
really lose
however Kirishima continues to question
himself for a while and Haku G even
notices the fear in his eyes
nevertheless Konishi must steps in to
take some of rafa's brutal punches in
fat gums place the instant his hardening
gets broken kadhi Shima just re hardens
again and he does much better against
the bullet punches than before
in this way he buys enough time for
factum to prepare his finisher attack
despite all the fears in kanishka's mind
his number one fear that surpassed all
the others was reverting back to his old
self who could only watch in the face of
danger he's now committed to being a
hero who can protect people fat gum says
that his opponents lost for one reason
because they underestimated kitty Shima
then he launches his attacks saying get
a taste of the manly heart of the hero
named red riot by the end of it kiddush
most severely injured but he succeeded
in changing himself he succeeded in not
being the kind of person that simply
stands by and watches while others are
in danger at this point he's unconscious
and factum is extremely touched by
karishma's display of manliness even
rap-off who manages to get up despite
his injuries tells fathom to tend to
kitayama's wounds referring to him as a
man hyk ichi tries to stop him but wrap
attacks his own teammate even rapa was
affected by how Kirishima put his life
on the line he wants him to get better
so that they can fight again someday
man-to-man factum thinks about how
Kirishima was a man who understood his
own weakness he issue I acknowledged
that he used to be pathetic but he
showed himself in this fight to be a
true man who even the enemy acknowledged
so those are some of the more important
highlights for Kirishima and there's
sure to be some more epic moments with
him as the series goes on but despite
all the work and training he still has
ahead of him it is truly inspiring to
see how he succeeded in changing himself
he went from a scared negative kid who
could only watch when others were in
trouble - one of the manliest and most
positive dudes who is willing to throw
himself at even the straw
villains even if it means risking his
life it's a character art that truly
inspires me and I hope you can draw some
inspiration from the Manley read riot as
well there's a lesson here don't assume
that you can't change yourself perhaps
you can't all at once but kayashima is a
testament to the fact that you can
change yourself for the better if you
consistently work towards doing so we
touched on Kadesh MUSC work a bit but
let's take a closer look at it now
his quirk is hardening and it allows him
to harden and sharpen his body parts
this hardening can be used as a strong
defense and offense the drawback is that
Kanishka has a limit to how much damage
he can take the hardening gets weaker
after accumulating a lot of damage and
eventually stops working altogether
while it is activated his hardening
ability lets him break through walls and
survive giant robots falling on him
hardening allows him to be explosion
heat and shockwave resistant his moves
are pretty straightforward we talked
about his bulldozer fighting style read
counter consists of taking damage and
then countering with a straight punch
read gauntlet is Kitty Schmo running
towards an enemy and punching them his
most flashy ability is definitely the
red ride unbreakable mode we discussed
earlier which allows him to reach his
maximum hardening level in this form he
appears jagged and monstrous but also
cool AF by continuously reharden
he was able to withstand wrap ups strong
and quick punches for a significant
period of time and he even managed to
survive many Pro heroes wouldn't be able
to withstand the same kind of attacks
when the unbreakable mode is introduced
Kirishima says that he can maintain this
unbreakable form for about 40 seconds
but in theory he should be able to get
even harder and last for longer as the
series goes on man I feel like almost
every sentence in this video is going to
sound like a double entendre but that's
what you get when you talk about a guy
who's super power is being hard anyways
thank you so much for watching if we can
get 5,000 that's right 5,000 likes on
this video I will start on the next one
ASAP let me know what inspiring
character from MHA you would like me to
talk about next if you haven't be sure
to subscribe and this is critical hit
that notification bell or else you won't
know when new MHA videos come out for
more my hero academia content and
crucial updates about the new seasons
makes
to follow us on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar a big thank you goes out to
our patrons over on patreon who help
make videos like this one possible I'm
blown away by the amount of patience we
have and I'm extremely thankful to each
and every one of you I especially want
to thank our pro hero tier patrons the
one and only gilgamesh baby ray nothing
but a fan Jason Wilson Kings I'll just
$30.00 beat at Karachi and Anatole
Cassatt's key DJ Nathaniel alpha deal
and angel Cruz and are the one tier
patrons the ones who stay atop all clans
Stephan and Radha a Lola naught I'm
Matty Mac 239 makoto-kun Seth Cooper and
the world if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon comm
anime out drawer and becoming a patron
today for as little as $1 if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here and you leaving at access for
private patron only discord so check out
patreon.com/crashcourse
[Music]
you
[Music]